hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
doublelift made his return to the LCS
this weekend on Team Liquid after taking
a hiatus from playing with TSM now his
move to TL surprised everybody so we're
counting down the top 10 most shocking
traits in LPS history double is shocking
addition to Team Liquid this would has
earned the number 10 spot after being a
key component to TSM team fans were
shocked when doublelift
decided to leave the team to pursue
streaming now he's back in the LCS this
time on Team Liquid for the remainder of
the spring split I'm really glad I took
a break because if I didn't take this
break I might still I might still be a
pro but I might like resent it or I
might not be as motivated as I am now
coming in at number 9 is gbn who left
generic green wings in the lck to lose
to energy in the NA LCS after proving to
be a strong mid laner in Korea GBM
switched to na was highly anticipated
while energy showed a lot of potential
the team eventually terminated contracts
with the entire lineup making GBM a free
agent it's really just a fight base are
you laughter - from GBS wipes the health
bars of cloud 9
the dongers goes off but it only sets
objects and to be taken down and a very
bold call by cloud 9 goes very wrong
this could be how energy gets back into
the game
froggen surprising move from elements to
echo fox in season 6 grabbed our 8th
spot after being seen as the face of the
EU LCS his switch to na came as a huge
surprise to the community after elements
struggled in the EU LCS froggen was
given a fresh start on echo fox in the
hopes to reclaim his former clerk an
assignment - rocket exile because
there's another kill for autumn as he
takes down well but oh shut up that was
looping today clooney and reignover
switch from fnatic twin mortals comes in
at number 7 on our list the duo had a
breakthrough debut in the EU together
leading fnatic to an undefeated summer
split and a strong run to the world
semi-finals after establishing
themselves as a powerhouse duo their
synergy landed them a spot on na the
mortals looking to say support also he's
been closed out which is good
much damaged up before he gets locked up
by that racial term now if you wicked
rooted in place Rudy it's going to put
the damage from a fire get out clearly
rain over and Rudy with a perfect
perfect yang another famous Delos I
grabbed the six spot honor list our Zen
and Missy both players had been with
origin since it was founded in December
2014 the botlane duo abruptly left the
organization after a disappointing
midseason Invitational and g2 made them
an offer they couldn't refuse
while the rumors seemed crazy at the
time origin fans felt betrayed when it
became a reality
yep putting on their forgiving Vanden
impersonation and actually put xdk
slightly behind the tempo but exactly
the same is going to happen because
rocket has no words to see them they're
not invading as fast for the topsides
over your mini-map but I wonder if
there's going to be a kill secured
Freddie's going low over the summer to
air lacks exhaust comes out solid by a
flash Michigan
[Applause]
coming in at number five is yellow stars
move from fanatic to TSN after having
been with fanatic since January 2013 and
leading them to five titles in six EU
LCS splits it came as a shock when
yellow star decided to make the move to
TSM yellow star was brought on to pair
with double list in the bot lane in the
hopes that the two would combine their
mechanics and leadership skills after a
brief stint in na he eventually rejoined
fnatic fnatic it was like they are going
to lose it
coming across well you asked arrow of
beautiful jobs with all the way down the
middle of recklessness move from fnatic
to elements earns the fourth spot on our
list many claimed that reckless was the
best western ad carry and his decision
to leave fnatic proved that he would do
anything to become the best at the time
elements looks like a promising choice
in the EU LCS for him
I feel like element is a more motivated
team which is something that fits me
well because I feel like I'm still in my
prime time I still want to play the game
as much as he possibly can however his
debut on elements against fnatic marks
the start of a downfall for his career
on elements we're down to the top three
most shocking LCS roster trade our third
spot goes to Edward who went from gambit
gaming to team curse a trade that would
go down in history Edward made history
joining team curse and they became the
first team to import an EU player into
the NA LCS the news came as a shock to
many as gambit gaming had built a
reputation as one of the most consistent
rosters in comparison to other proteins
well they don't any partner gonna place
us all but one of they requested us go
super to play as well what kinda party
throws down the jumpers that walk the
most backward picks up first board
grabbing our second place spot its
piglets move from SKT in the lck to team
curse which rebranded to Team Liquid in
na piglet being the first world champion
to make the move to na created a lot of
hype for the team's biggest undeniable
talents earned him an offer in na that
he accepted deciding it was the right
move for him
you can't burn through this Barrett an
ad carry big bottle up with a pack one
sale
doublelift mood from CLG to PSN took
fans by surprise and earned the number
one spot on our list
doublelift made a name for himself on
GOG as one of the best ad carries in na
after being a removed from CLG his team
of four years he received an offer on
TSN joining clg's biggest regional
rivals doublelift was able to thrive on
PSN and soon became a fundamental part
of their victories da all goes down for
TSM doublelift are throughout the fight
dangle our star watch bacon and there
you have it these were our picks for the
top 10 most shocking roster trades in
LCS history do you agree or disagree or
maybe we forgot something we want to
hear in the comments below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button